oh my god
do you remember when we went on that
trip uh right after
we gave birth a few months later and we
were like okay let's get the girls
together
let's get out of the house and see the
sun
and we went to mexico it was so fun
we had so much fun and we needed to get
away because i i also think about the
importance of having
your community of girlfriends
to be able to say i'm exhausted can i
pass you the baby or i'm weaning
how come my hormones are all over the
place and i still think we don't have
enough resources for for women who are
going through childbirth and
and the the ups and downs of hormones i
mean child birth to menopause we don't
have enough resources
information um and i think
my girlfriends have saved my life i mean
in the sense that
i could have never done it without the
network of support of other women going
rhys it was supposed to be at school
next
next monday and i'm like what because
sometimes i'm
in the clouds creatively and um but my
girlfriends always keep the trains
running
and they keep me you know safe and sane
i don't know where i would be without my
friends i mean they were
you know my family wasn't really there
in the beginning
nor you know my dad he took off before i
was born
and um and i don't have any baggage with
him i was like okay incapable person
like i just always really dug him i was
like you're cool man
you're cool can i stay true it is so
incredibly healing that you have always
been this incred this
transparent person because i think more
people have your experience than don't
have your experience
and it's incredibly healing to see that
not only did you find a way to work
through all those things
you found a group of friends that are
your family
and you have become this incredible
mother
incredible and i think there's a great
message out there and i i think if
anything i would just say like
please just always be your open
vulnerable self because
your your story has changed so many
people's lives and
everybody loves seeing you succeed
because there's some piece of us that we
all feel a little bit broken you know
and and whatever it is whatever you
share you don't share
when you heal that brokenness or you
watch somebody
like you heal their brokenness you feel
like you can do it yourself
and that is a gift that you give so many
people and i think that's why every time
i see you
on tv i smile well
if i survived in this world
i really give a tremendous credit to
the friends i had and the women i know
who are just trying to figure out their
lives
and if there's one thing i think that
we need in this world it's not to feel
alone because i'll tell you this
when you're a kid and you don't have
family around you you look around and
you come out of your room and you go
where is everybody hello
and when you have a big family and a lot
of love you're like i'm in my room
and you slam the door and the metaphor
is you need a lot of great people around
you to
want to be alone because lonely and
alone
are so vastly different that is really
well said
so lonely and alone are different oh i
never thought about that
like one is tragic and one is
awesome
[Music]
and you make people feel less lonely and
more capable of being alone
thank you friend and what i really
appreciate is that you're addressing
social issues that you are addressing
race you are addressing
you know women's equalities time's up
you are also really an advocate
while you are finding these important
things that are happening in our society
and
addressing them as well well you know i
have a lot of inspiration from having
two teenagers in my house
um you know someone i don't know
somewhere i read if you're not talking
about
race and class and wealth inequality
and social issues with your children
they're talking about it with somebody
else and and
that hit me very profoundly because this
is the world they're inheriting
and if we don't take our positions of um
influence or whatever your influence is
you know
whether you're the principal at a school
or you're the
um you know the head of your book club
you have a power to influence thoughts
and ideas and
that's why i love books as well because
books have changed my life by going
absolutely nowhere i grew up in
nashville tennessee and i just
lost myself in a book and it it made me
see like i felt like i could see the
world i could see other people's
opinions
i could see where people lived a
completely different experience than me
so
i would say books are the antidote to
bigotry and
and um small thinking you know it's
about being expansive but
i'm so you know i feel really really
blessed to have these kids in my life
and to have all the children of the
world
out there the greta tunbergs and the
parkland
um kids just really inspiring us to do
more and create a better
world thank you for being someone i've
known throughout my life
and i want to know throughout the rest
of my life you are a great woman
a great mother and a great friend and
you're good to me and you're good to
everyone else out there too
well i love you drew have a great show
and
next time we're gonna sit on the couch
together
and have a little have a little tea and
just spill the tea
i cannot wait it's gonna be so much fun
thank you reese